all right we are at it again I was not
sure whether I was going to stream the
press briefing today or oh my god I look
crazy again or the Wisconsin election
results because there is voting
happening tonight in Wisconsin jeez this
hair has become really becoming a
distraction guys I'm sorry about it
anyway I decided I'm in a stream twice
we're doing this stream and then I'll
stream again close to 9:00 p.m. Eastern
which is when a polls close in Wisconsin
but as a result I probably will only
stream a little bit right now we'll take
questions and comments and all that
stuff and we'll do a little bit of the
press conference then I'll probably have
to stop because I've got to work on
tomorrow's show have dinner deal with
this by showering and all that type of
stuff and then I will be back for the
Wisconsin results stream now it's crazy
that people are voting in Wisconsin
ipoed it posted earlier look at these
crowds in Wisconsin some people wearing
masks and you know there's the idea sort
of of socially distancing that guy has
his mask down to drink coffee which I
don't know how much the mask helps if
it's around your neck but this is crazy
I mean this is we were told it's not
even safe to go to the grocery store by
dr. Burks yesterday and Saturday and yet
people are mass gathering in Wisconsin
and they're voting and it's absolutely
and completely bonkers but because there
is an election I will be here I will be
here tonight again with election results
and that is what is going on okay
brief note I we've we've got a bunch of
clips coming out about chloroquine and
you know the Trump propagandizing around
chloroquine and I just to remember
everybody you know when I criticize
Trump and others for promoting
chloroquine like a miracle cure it's not
because I think chloroquine has no
potential remember this is not to Pat
myself on the back but we started
covering chloroquine two weeks before
Trump started promoting it we've also
been talking about a began
Ramdas aveer a variety of HIV drugs
things under development and you know
there's no real reason to be going crazy
about one of them
it's causing shortages of the drug for
people using it for approved conditions
it you know etc etc so but one thing I
want to make clear there's now a story
that the explanation of Trump for Trump
promoting chloroquine is merely that he
has a financial interest in it I want to
warn progressives not to go down this
route the the story for me is number one
Novartis which is one of the
manufacturers paid Michael Cohen a
million bucks for consulting which means
access to Trump they make chloroquine
that I would be looking at a lot of the
people around Trump are connected to
companies that make it Trump owns
through a trust which invests in a
mutual fund which has 2.9 percent of
that fund in Sanofi it's possible Trump
has a few hundred dollars worth of
Sanofi through this mutual fund I I
don't think that's the right approach
trumps promotion of this as a miracle
cure is wrong for many reasons but I
just don't think it makes sense to go
after him for a few hundred bucks the
guy you know whether he has four billion
or 1 billion whatever Trump is wealthy
enough that he's not gonna be making
decisions based on a few hundred dollars
in stock so I don't think that that's
really the right approach for us on the
same side of the of the equation so to
speak okay so we got that out of the way
all right let's get an update on the
latest numbers the latest official
global numbers are now 1.4 million cases
the real number we don't know a deaths
is now eighty one thousand five hundred
huge number we will soon be in the
double digits yesterday there were a
total of 73 thousand new cases and over
5,000 deaths today so far we are at 73
thousand new cases and it's still early
and nearly seven thousand deaths
once again the worst day today yesterday
in the u.s. we had 30,000 new cases and
twelve fifty five deaths today so far we
are already at nearly 1700 deaths
updated numbers in the United States
three hundred and ninety one thousand
official cases twelve thousand five
61 deaths still New York and New Jersey
big epicenters however Michigan now
closing in on 20,000 cases California
and Louisiana have passed 15,000
Pennsylvania and Florida and
Massachusetts in Illinois are right
there updated model from IH m-e the
latest update says that we are nine days
from the peak remember that the peak is
really more of a plateau that will last
a while the peak deaths on April 16th
now expected to be 3100 if you look at
this model you will see that there is a
period of from the seventh until the
seventh until the 26th that's nineteen
days during which there will be more
than 2,000 deaths so when we talk about
a peak we're really talking about almost
a three-week period during which there
will be many many deaths the latest
update on total deaths in this wave is
81 thousand seven hundred and sixty-six
with a sort of confidence interval
saying it will be somewhere between 49
and a hundred and thirty six thousand
deaths that's wave one remember we're
expecting a second wave in the fall when
flu season comes back and a third wave
in 2021 so these numbers are by August
four so these are just wave 1
projections ok so that's the latest
update in terms of the model we are
standing by for the Whitehouse
coronavirus task force press briefing if
you're just joining me on Twitter
twitch YouTube or Facebook I will remind
you that this will be a short earth
stream because I will be back for a
second stream tonight for the Wisconsin
Democratic primary results and some
other actual important races again I'm
against anybody voting there today but
they are voting so I will bring you the
results one other thing just as a funny
thing I did steal from my girlfriend I
don't know what kind of brush you call
this I've never used a brush like this
before I'm considering teasing my hair
with this maybe if we get to you know
our 25 web
site member goal during the stream i am
i will consider teasing my hair with
this people yesterday suggested that i
do it i have the brush it's this it's an
incredible brush i mean it's one of the
best brushes i've seen in the sense that
it's the only one and I will consider
teasing I mean it's like who cares I'm
gonna shower after this before tonight's
stream anyway so the brush is here
alright the brush is here and a lot of
concern if you look at my subreddit at
david pakman.com slash read it you will
see a lot of concern for my disheveled
appearance yesterday it's I'm just not
shaving or cutting my hair that's all
every I feel fine for the time being
knock on wood and and you know all of
that stuff but that's where we are right
now
okay thank you very much I am NOT gonna
do bingo today the link still works the
link from yesterday's bingo page still
works but because it's gonna be an
abbreviated stream for me because I've
got to go and work on tomorrow's show
shower dinner before the nighttime
stream feel free to play bingo I am NOT
going to do bingo because it's unlikely
that I can stay through the end of the
question period now one question about
tonight is whether we will see Donald
Trump's new press secretary Kaylee
McKenna nee we'll get to that
momentarily okay I'm gonna get to some
super chats before I do that let me say
thanks to Shaun Mahoney Shaun is new
member number one today at join
pakman.com very much appreciate your
support
Shaun okay super chats send yours
Kristen Swanson grabs a YouTube
membership waffles derp awful says hair
emergency intervention press conference
incoming pair Taryn says young Einstein
hair McNally says fYI bonus show is up
today but not the full show we know
Kowalski from Nebraska says David
looking more like Cody from some more
news amber white says I have info to
nurses from different counties in
Florida that the numbers are wrong
clinics are paying to keep deaths out of
the news also paperwork changed okay I
don't know about that but feel free to
email me information Cinna Vasek says
I'm fortunate enough to live in a small
town in Wisconsin no more than 3 people
voting at a time pandemic or
not Godin got out sanitized terrible for
more populated areas very much so very
much so
Stephen Strobel says Pakman thanks for
working nonstop to provide excellent
coverage and smart analysis of the
nonstop flurry of info you make it
easier to stay updated Thank You HS DTE
says you know you could have easily won
counterclaims against those DMCA claims
against you
oh we're fighting every one of them
we're fighting every one of them parity
Ren says I think that he promotes that
medication because that is the longest
word that he can almost vocalize yeah
but you know Trump has to pause Trump
will say hydroxy chloroquine he like
can't say the entire thing together I've
noticed Charlie says if you had to pick
either Stephen Miller or pence as your
roommate who do you choose the apartment
is very small probably pence he seems
more docile that would be that would be
probably my choice all he says in the UK
only deaths that occur in a hospital are
counted I I don't know that to be true
but I'll research that Carolina's
Altamirano says hey you cool cats and
kittens Deb Kemper has grabbed the
YouTube membership key K says any
thoughts on Trump removing stimulus
watchdog we've got a big story on that
tomorrow so I don't want to preempt I
don't want a self cuck and pre ant
preempted my story tomorrow so I'm gonna
wait on discussing that in more detail
let me say thank you to British lass for
subscribing with twitch prime AC has
gifted to subscriptions on Twitch and C
Cheney has also subscribed with prime
very much appreciated ok this is Donald
Trump's new press secretary now you
might say who was his blast press
secretary and you would be right to ask
about that because his last press
secretary Stephanie Grisham never did a
briefing the last briefing was early
March of 2019 it's been 13 months since
the last briefing Stephanie Grisham has
come and gone
this is Donald Trump's new press
secretary take a listen to this insanity
the coronavirus and the president saying
you know what we're not gonna take
people in from China right now I mean
isn't it just a matter of protecting us
our national security really being at
stake and he's sort of the last line of
defense there or first I should say
absolutely this president will always
put America first he will always protect
American citizens we will not see
diseases like the corona virus come here
we will not see terrorism come here and
isn't that refreshing when contrasting
it with the awful presidency of
President Obama right so she now is the
press secretary okay so in general you
know this would be the type of
incoherent rant that would get you it
would be career-ending right if if the
world was fair and actions had
consequences that were precise I guess I
would say well-balanced she would now no
longer be able to get any kind of job in
the public eye instead she's rewarded by
becoming the press secretary of the
President of the United States
everything's backwards okay everything
is completely backwards let me see what
else I had here for you let me see if we
have an update from Trump on today's
press conference nope nothing there let
me see if there's anything on my Twitter
page oh yeah so this is yesterday people
were very very concerned about my hair
and it continues to get worse and it
probably will I posted the video I just
played for you oh and here's today's
stream okay all right so we're good as
far as that goes and we are standing by
for the Donald Trump press conference at
the top of the hour let me also say
thank you to game Rex for gifting five
community subscriptions over on Twitch
if you're watching on YouTube please do
me the favor of hitting that like button
and hit the subscribe button
both are key they cost nothing and they
personally helped me they really do okay
Christine Kinsella sends a super chat
joke rockin Berg says a lot of grocery
store workers will end up sick
undoubtedly undoubtedly zesty African
says how do you have so much drip its
genetic I think I think its genetic
uh let me see here Amin al rifai II says
I'm quite surprised you didn't butcher
my name yesterday thank you
Zappa GOG says ladies and gentlemen
please remember to snap the snot slap
the snot out of that like button exactly
John the fourth says voted in Milwaukee
today it's a complete disaster agree
with you
Tiffany jane says thankful to be able to
work from home so I grabbed a membership
the other day long time watcher
wondering if you keep in touch with
Louis absolutely Louis and I and a
couple other elementary school friends
had a zoom hangout the other day Louis
recommended a video game to me called
Baba is you and because things are so
crazy I'm actually playing a video game
and that video game is called
something's wrong with my earphone here
that game is called Baba is you and it's
quite a good game it's difficult it's a
difficult puzzle game but I am enjoying
it okay let me very briefly go over to
twitch and just see what the general
vibe is in the chat a lot of people
arguing with Hassan pikers viewers I
don't know what that has to do with
anything people like the game Baba is
you some people asking me to stream Baba
is you a lot of people asking me to
stream baba is you and I might like the
witness someone suggests and a lot of
people saying hello okay very good well
I love checking in with everybody and
appreciate everybody who's been
following on on Twitch and we will be
streaming tonight on Twitter's well if
you're just joining us I will be here
for part of today's press briefing then
I have to do all sorts of preparation
including dealing with my hair because
we've got another stream tonight for the
Wisconsin Democratic primary and other
results thanks to no flow fo sho
for grabbing a twitch Prime subscription
as well okay other super chats
continuing to come in
Martin person has subscribed on YouTube
Cameron Pratt
says have you seen the channel bad
empanadas no I have not
Michel 23 says yeah no coronavirus in
the US all right 390 1000 confirmed
cases three times more than anyone
according to the ROI lab stat stream
Brandon diamond says hey love from
Canada thanks Brandon Vardhan says thank
you for always being straightforward
when you know you have a bias but I
appreciate you being blunt yes indeed
Adam ohne says thanks David great job
and make it simple says please stream
that game Lewis recommended I'll think
about that
Matthias Vargas says I'm a nurse and the
3d printed face masks they're giving us
break after a few uses I've read that
and that is not good that is very very
not good we are standing by for the top
of the hour at which time we are
expecting Donald Trump although
yesterday he was 45 minutes late we have
no live video yet from the room we will
also keep an eye on Donald Trump's
Twitter feed sometimes he will push
things back up to 45 minutes like he did
yesterday nothing so far but we are
standing by does anybody know if there
is any live feed right now in the room
PBS and c-span are not live in the room
and I always prefer to be live in the
room well you can let me know and if
people are looking to play bingo today
you can moderators are pasting the link
to the bingo page and you can you can
find it there I won't be playing today
because it'll be an abbreviated session
for me let's see here
is there anybody live in the room
Washington Post was live earlier okay
let me see if I can grab that and pull
it up and then we're going to continue
Washington Post coronavirus live let's
take a look here ah here we go
Washington Post is indeed live in the
room
let's go over to that always like to
keep an eye on the hijinks taking place
in the room there we go still uh doing
something I wonder what that's a
apparently dealing with some kind of
lighting or something like that very
interesting okay let me very briefly say
so you know yesterday I tried this and
it really worked well so I'm gonna
continue doing it I'm gonna limit my
enticements to get a website membership
to just one okay here's my very short
pitch everything we do is mostly funded
by memberships at join pakman.com that's
me being very very straight with you in
march three hundred and eighty nine
people canceled memberships that's a lot
for us we've never had so many people
cancel and i get why we all know why
right unemployment may hit twenty
percent people are working reduced hours
layoffs etc we've already had several
dozen people cancel in april so my goal
is we don't want to have to impact any
staff or contractor hours we want to
just keep writing things out now
unfortunately youtube revenues down
thirty five percent again in total more
than 400 people have canceled
I don't want your last two dollars but
if it's affordable for you to support us
at two dollars a month or twenty for the
year which is like a dollar eighty for a
month go to join pakman.com and get a
membership the coupon code 2020 now
saves you sixty-six percent don't feel
obligated to take it but take it if you
want those memberships are what is kind
of fighting this huge decline that we've
experienced plus the thirty five percent
decline on YouTube because YouTube uses
a barter system if more advertisers want
to advertise the the price of an ad gets
bid up and we make more money when fewer
advertisers are looking to advertise ads
are cheaper we split that with YouTube
it goes down so join pakman.com is the
place the website resources have been
doubled since last week because
sometimes things would crash when i
mentioned this on stream so that is my
that is my my suggestion and i
appreciate everybody who's been signing
up
okay they are unveiling the televisions
in advance of the stream and we will see
how late Donald Trump is today let me
say thanks to Curt Wells who says just
grabbed a yearly subscription keep up
the good work thanks Curt Mary Allen has
grabbed a youtube subscription Diane
marzin e says I'm a real estate agent in
Tucson I miss hugging my kids thanks for
hanging with us
I have very close friends in Tucson and
I've been there many times look forward
to being back again someday cosas de
luna says my smallish hometown is
underreported with the Texas Health
websites
taking 5 days to update case numbers
wonder if other localities have the same
problem I would assume so we are hearing
a lot of that we are hearing a lot of
that Gian says did you hear about
Mercedes Carrera going to jail I did
Mercedes Carrera is a gamer porn star
that I interviewed years ago during the
gamergate fiasco and I guess her real
name is like something Smith like Pam
Smith or I don't remember exactly and
she uh I guess she was like accused of
sex trafficking or something anyway that
was a weird phase in the David Pakman
show people asking if I'm ready for
Passover I mean to the extent that I'll
go and buy the chocolate-covered
marshmallows and chocolate-covered matzo
I'm ready but I'm not going to be going
to a seder this year because it's not
safe and Passover is all but completely
canceled all but completely canceled and
it is what it is my friends know uh I'll
have to get my matzo ball soup at
Michael's deli in Brookline rather than
at a Passover Seder joke rockin Berg
says well places get sued for not
protecting employees anything is
possible at this point
Daniel Krieger says Trump Trump just
removed the kovat 19 funding watchdog I
will have a full report about that for
you tomorrow my friends
Christine cancellous has just got Galaxy
series great suggestion thank you yes
very very good
okay excellent a few other super chats
Oh est African has signed up at the SOI
boy level Christian Burchell says I live
in Orlando last week most of the stores
were not allowing X amount of people
this week it's like everyone has
forgotten about the virus yeah I've seen
that at a number of stores here in the
Boston area limiting the number of
people long lines outside socially
distanced lines with pieces of tape it's
it's it's a dystopian surreal
circumstance but it is what it is and
we're we're all just living in it
we're all just living in it Jim Eadie
says greetings from Switzerland enjoying
the stream as always thanks Jimmy
very much appreciate that qumola
reichert says watched a clip from Korea
where someone took tylenol to bypass a
checkpoint checking for fever is not as
safe now
listen when twenty to fifty percent of
people never have symptoms checking for
fever
you know Trump says we've been screening
it's almost meaningless especially when
as as you're suggesting you can just
take tylenol to get around screening
mascot says some strong news anchor hair
today yeah very very much so Ashley
Pearson says David I admire how
articulate you are do you have any
advice on developing or practicing the
skill for those of us that don't have it
not really I mean I think just putting
yourself in positions where you have to
think on your feet is the best thing
when I was how old was I when I was 16
17 I got a job at the now-defunct
Circuit City and I became a salesperson
on Commission where I was selling
warranties and products very strong
products exciting products of different
kinds and I needed to be able to you
know talk to all sorts of different
people and answer questions thinking on
my feet and I think that that is what
got me comfortable just kind of winging
it I guess is what I would say split
clips says David any truth any truth to
Novartis paying Michael Cohen for access
to Trump in 2018 yeah
we have a report about that today
already filmed it's in the can as we
like to say it's publishing later that
is my understanding of what happened
Vardhan says virtual Seder also awesome
metal band name yeah I like that
Oh in fact Seder reminds me Sam cedar
was texting me earlier today and we were
supposed to catch up but I don't know if
we're gonna have time today between this
stream and then the 9 p.m. Wisconsin
results stream I don't know Michelle
Weiss blot Dane says deutsche bank owns
Teva Pharmaceutical in deutsch owns
Trump I can prove it here's the thing
guys o chloroquine is generic so tons of
companies make it Novartis makes
chloroquine Bayer makes chloroquine
tavaa makes chloroquine Sanofi makes
chloroquine that's why any theory and
I'm using the term Theory colloquially
not scientifically any theory about
chloroquine conflicts of interest
remember that it's generic it's been
around since I believe 1934 tons of
people make chloroquine and just I want
everybody to to bear that in mind let me
say thank you to hold on a second the
Lord diabolos for subscribing on Twitch
heard about it
subscribed and says can you shout out
Katy at the CDC she's working hard and
watches your streams Katy at the CDC
thank you for your work follow people
who are actually doctors and scientists
don't be bullied by people like Donald
Trump Thank You Katy at the CDC Irish
slims has subscribed with prime vague
rach has subscribed with prime dave's
debt owed the best data has subscribed
with prime a be nurse has subscribed on
Twitch 24 pounds has subscribed on
Twitch keep rollin rollin rollin yo has
also cheered thank you very much
I really do appreciate that ok let me
say a few thank-yous now it is that time
where it is time to
start thanking people who have signed up
on my website let's see here
I want to say thank you to Kareem yari
who is new member number two at joined
pakman.com Michelle Alcazar is new
member number 3 Kurt Wells is new member
number 4 let me see here
Breck wood is new member number 5 at
join pakman.com Thank You Breck Griffin
Hughes is new member number six today at
join pakman.com Rebecca Rayburn Cooper
you are new member number seven Rebecca
Callaghan Fitzgerald it's like two last
names almost I like it is new member
number eight today tie McConnell is new
member number nine Shane Harvey Walker
is new member number ten chase Malley
fato is new member number eleven
Alexander Schofield is new member number
twelve today Tania Clarke is new member
number thirteen today Shane hearing is
new member number fourteen thanks Jane
Gideon hamburger not hamburger hamburger
Gideon Haim burger is new member number
fifteen today Daniel Colavecchia is new
member number sixteen
Martin Collins you are new member number
seventeen today Eileen Rader I hope I'm
pronouncing that correctly as new member
number eighteen
sandy Paige you are number 19 abdel al
staiin alse ngayon maybe is new member
number twenty Justin Olson is number 21
and Karolina altamirano is number 22
just as a reminder this is kind of a
joke okay but it's not a joke also I
stole my girlfriend's hairbrush I've
never used a hairbrush like this before
if we get to 25 members which we are
very close to we'll just see what
happens I'll tease my hair with this
hairbrush and I think it'll be a moment
of levity a moment of Zen so to speak
that will be very memorable me mobile
and giftable and I think a lot of people
will enjoy it really really strongly
okay Donna Williams says thank you for
your hard work
sorry Donna's message disappeared thank
you for your hard work from Southern
California I was scheduled to go to
Southern California very soon and I was
scheduled to do some very exciting
things there right you know what I'm
talking about but now it's not clear
when it's going to happen
Christopher hellström says would be
interesting to get your take on Sweden's
take on the outbreak I don't know that
much about what's been going on in
Sweden to be perfectly frank rillette
says what's the deal with the report on
Huffington Post that Trump has trust
with investment into hydroxychloroquine
company listen it looks like Trump owns
maybe a few hundred dollars of one of
the many companies that make chloroquine
I think it's a bad move for the left to
focus on that
Trump's behavior regarding chloroquine
has been irresponsible for reasons
totally unrelated to his stake in that
company Diane Mars and he says I am a
member of Toastmasters in Tucson I just
done wonders for me yeah once I went to
Boston Toastmasters it's an interesting
public speaking organization joke rockin
berg says my company publics made four
point six billion in profits last year
isn't even giving us hazard pay or
limiting customers many stores have
cases already horrible so sorry to hear
that Joe Kaylin Brooke says hey David
how is this pandemic affecting prisons
there are multiple prisons that have
cases and its effect i mean it's it's a
nightmare you know people in close
quarters and very problematic toon
Italica says hey David which is superior
to you chocolate babka black and white
cookie or chocolate rugelach chocolate
babka chocolate babka here's my list of
here let me give you guys the top
desserts okay and I consider chocolate
babka a dessert I want to make sure I
don't miss any of these because I have a
very specific list of what the top
desserts are here are the top desserts
chocolate babka okay
flan flan with dulce de leche
I'm Argentinean you have to anticipate
that that would be here flan is a top
dessert
a good tiramisu okay
pistachio baklava pistachio baklava I I
think those are the best for desserts
I'm trying to think if there's anything
else
oh yeah and halva
I love calva but I don't I consider it
more of a snack than a dessert it's you
know we're really kind of slicing and
dicing here but those those I believe
are essentially the best desserts I've
had there's one other that's more of a
nitch dessert which is it's a what would
you call it I don't know what the name
of it is but it's a chocolate it's like
al it's like a little round chocolate
cake that inside has hot melted
chocolate you understand what I'm saying
and when you kind of cut into it you get
a little bit of that hot chocolate it's
fantastic fantastic dessert oh that is
lava cake I did forget one other dessert
mochi mochi is very you know five years
ago if you had asked me who had even
heard of mochi five years ago to quote
Donald Trump but mochi is rapidly
becoming one of my one of my favorite
desserts as well okay let me thank a few
other people here uh Dominic Caro is new
member number 23 Jacob Nicholson is new
member number 24 Okin Cano is new member
number 25 on that note let's go for 50
my friends why not Angela castles is new
member number 26
Dominic Lehman is new member number 27
Diane Mars anni or Mars Oni is new
member number 28 Ivan Miranda is new
member number 29 also want to say thank
you to Simon person who's new member
number 30 grams Scarlett is number 31
David chalk is new member number 32 and
Michael Gavin is new member number 33
all right I promised I would do it at
someone's suggestion yesterday I did get
a brush
from my girlfriend and I'm just as we're
waiting I'm gonna try teasing the hair a
little bit just to see what happens
let's do it I said I would do it oh do
it this is not good it's creating some
kind of a static response it looks like
I think I think it's actually making the
lights flicker here you know it's really
not bad actually it does seem to be kind
of smoothing it out in a certain way let
me see here I don't know if this is
better or I don't know if this is better
or worse but I can kind of wrap around
the side there yep I think this is good
I think this helps guys I'm not actually
I'm kind of being serious okay I
actually think that it's it's better I
think it's better and be like I can run
my hands through it now in a beautiful
way Oh people are saying it's worse okay
also people are saying that doesn't
count as teasing I guess I don't really
know what that means what does it mean
to tease it anyway we did it I think
we're good
I actually this is completely under
control now I think I'm gonna be using
this live on during the show going
forward maybe this is teasing going like
this that's not helping at all
yeah it's actually that's actually
really bad all right let's just pull it
back and then we're gonna get back to
super chats and stuff like that there we
go this is crazy
okay I'm gonna have to backcomb it for
more height
yeah that's an idea I think we have to
stop I have towards the root okay listen
guys I've never used the brush before I
clearly don't know what I'm doing okay
listen if we get 250 website members I
will do a back comb and we'll see what
happens but for the time being I think
we're gonna put the comb down all right
we are standing by for a press briefing
from Donald Trump we don't know if it
has been delayed oh he says 5:30 okay so
we're about 13 minutes very good
yesterday it was delayed 45 minutes
today it looks like it's only a
15-minute delay
30 minute delay I also have installed an
element I guess I would call it call the
volume master because a lot of these
briefings have extremely low native
sound levels and I've installed volume
master and it worked beautifully
yesterday so we we are able we're gonna
be able to get a good audio signal I'm
convinced convinced during today's
stream ok Safra geum says thank you
david and crew appreciate your sharing
your educated knowledge stay healthy and
stay safe out there
Thank You suffrage emi appreciate it
thanks the space chase dried mangoes
says my wife Jojo says your stay home
hair game is strong thank you yeah I
appreciate it
koi Riley has grabbed the YouTube
membership inconsolable says I'm not a
bernie should get out of the way type of
guy but when news came out that
Wisconsin was going ahead with the
election shouldn't Bernie have dropped
out to save lives listen the reality is
that there were a lot of other elections
happening today in Wisconsin so it's not
it's it's not really I think Bernie's
done but it's not just a Bernie issue
there's a judgeship under election
there's a lot going on and to just blame
Bernie I think would not be fair it
would not be fair The Apprentice
double-oh-seven says why are we still
here just to suffer yeah to suffer and
boredom basically Dean Oldfield has
grabbed a soy boy level subscription
where did that go dream of the 90s says
lost my uncle David to the rona this
morning he had been on a ventilator for
a week my condolences so sorry to hear
that at this point almost everyone you
know it's gone from knowing someone who
has it to knowing someone who's serious
and and unfortunately more and more
people knowing someone who has passed
away really sorry to hear that and every
single one of these deaths extremely sad
extremely extremely sad increasingly
we're seeing people in the coronavirus
press briefing room where
not only gloves but also we're seeing
more masks there we are wondering
whether Donald Trump's new press
secretary Kayleigh McKenna nee will be
trotted out along with Donald Trump
today and maybe even left to field
questions we talked about her earlier
this week she now is Trump's new press
secretary and Trump's last press
secretary Stephanie Grisham did
absolutely no press briefings at all so
we don't even know if Kayleigh McKenna
knee is going to do press briefings we
just have no idea but we will soon see
Rasmus haymaker says what are conspiracy
theories you've heard about yourself
oh um let's see conspiracy theories you
know I was once featured in a
documentary about gay teenagers who had
sadly committed suicide and I had to
issue a statement through my
representatives that I was not a
teenager I think I was 27 at the time I
was not gay I had not been bullied and I
was alive so that was a really weird
conspiracy about me
you can google you can find that on my
youtube channel we've got a number of
clips about that generally there are
conspiracies that you know Soros funds
my show the DNC funds my show etc Israel
funds my show and the truth is you guys
fund my show people like let me thank
some of those people people like Jeff :
fund my show who is new member number
forty 34 people like Timmy Peterson
funds my show who is new member number
35 Raymond Raymond Raymond funds my show
who is new member number 36
Jose Barrios funds my show he's new
member number 37 Alexander Kaltenborn is
new member number 38 Lindsey
Joel or Lindsey Joelle is new member
number 39
Kevin valance is new member number 40
and Suzanne Brown is new member number
41 these are the people who fund my show
you know not George Soros not not Israel
or the DNC
or anything like that okay let me say
thank you to CR for ID who has
subscribed with twitch prime silent
night has subscribed with Prime and
skyline 5 GTR has subscribed with prime
as well thank you very much what do you
guys think is going on in the ceiling
that they've been they've been modifying
I have this crazy idea tell me if you
think this is a crazy idea I'm wondering
if there is lighting being modified so
that it is more what would be the word
complimentary to Trump's new press
secretary Kaley mckennon II is that a
completely crazy conspiracy theory to
think that they are modifying the
lighting to suit her better and Trump is
going to trot her out is that is that
completely out of school to suggest that
that may be it oh people are saying it's
not a crazy idea interesting interesting
we'll see we'll see if they trot her out
okay Dan crin has sent a super chat
private maka telly says Bernie Bernie
logic and civics K through 12 please
young reckless has sent a super chat dan
Crenn says hey David any thoughts on big
cats in the bronze soo testing positive
for kovat 19 I assume you mean the Bronx
Zoo I don't really have any thoughts
other than some people went nuts saying
did testing a tiger take a test away
from a human and we were told the answer
is no that these are totally separate
tests and that that was not a factor if
you're joining us on Twitter twitch
YouTube or Facebook the 5 p.m. Eastern
Time press briefing has been rescheduled
to 5:30 we are now seven minutes from
that I will be here for part of it but I
have to run early today because I'm
coming back tonight for a Wisconsin
election results stream 2 streams today
plus the broadcast show so I'm gonna
need to take a little time in between to
work on tomorrow's show have dinner deal
with this and you know all that type of
thing if you're joining me on you
- please do me the favor of hitting the
like button and the subscribe button
like and subscribe both very very much
appreciated
Justin tyranny has grabbed a YouTube
membership samantha marks says thanks
for the crazed hair it gives me a smile
every day when I join you much
appreciated
yeah who knows how long it's going to
last I have a feeling it could be a
while okay let's see here
Alex Jones says dave rubin said the rise
of socialism caused the corona virus he
has called you a liar repeatedly what
are your thoughts I'm only aware of dave
rubin calling me a liar once and it was
during an event a year or more ago and i
have no idea who he takes money from and
if he called me a liar multiple times
i'd be interesting interested in seeing
the video but i'm only aware of him
saying that once porthole says will
trump supporters ever see this as a
disaster no forget about it the answer
is no jonas Felix says from Switzerland
do you think there will be many with
symptoms not sinking seeking a doctor
due to fear from health care costs and
even continuing to work due to fear of
job loss could it drive us infections
yes and it's probably already happening
realistically astra comical says what
would be us sentiment if trump died of
kovat someone asked me that yesterday i
have no idea i truly don't know I mean
listen I don't want anyone to die of
kovat no matter who it is I I don't wish
death upon anyone that's my view okay
let me say a few other thank-yous mark
Kido is new member number 42 today
Susanne Braun is new member number 43
today very much appreciate your support
and if indeed we get to 50 members
before this starts I will back comb my
hair with this crazy brush I already did
a front comb which didn't make it too
crazy I am willing to go the opposite
direction against the grain so to speak
a
as we as we wait for this to start a
rich ro path AK says between the Browns
such as myself and the blacks which
group is the bigger eyesore in Boston
that's an extraordinarily racist and
disgusting question which I would never
take seriously because I reject it on
principle zest the African says why does
jimmy dore criticise bernie as if he was
a majority leader wielding tons of power
I have no idea I've not seen a clip of
Jimmy door for I don't even know I mean
look up on my youtube channel the last
time I talked about Jimmy that's the
last time I saw a clip of his show I
don't know anything about it
Zach Nichols says David as a
Wisconsinite I was lucky to get my mail
invalid on time do you have any idea why
Republicans would want to keep our
election today well I think it has to do
with a judgeship a judges race that's
taking place in Wisconsin I'm gonna get
caught up I'm gonna review all of the
elements of the races happening there
before tonight's live stream I will be
streaming results tonight out of
Wisconsin
bubah 44 says watching issue watching
youtube all night no issues this stream
for 60 P I I don't know everything seems
fine on our end and we are streaming in
HD streaming in HD my friends skunk
games says as a bald man I've I've never
been more jealous yeah my brother is
actually bald it's crazy he lost his
hair around age 20 and somehow I have
this I just I just don't know I don't
know shadow Louise has grabbed a youtube
membership James Dorn says is there a
way to combat people who are just smart
enough that they think they're
intelligent for example Fox News Trump
supporters obviously it's a problem for
all political parties in the US I've not
found a way to combat it from an
electoral perspective the way to combat
it is don't even argue with them just
try to get the voters to turnout because
half the country doesn't vote if you're
saying how can you actually change the
mind of an individual
like that who's just smart enough
actually let me see if I have this vid
this video I have a video clip of
someone who fits that description
perfectly
let me see if I can find it I believe it
was on yesterday's show let me take a
look here yes okay here we go
this is an example of a woman who has
just enough cognitive capacity to kind
of like memorized talking points but
she's an absolute loon and there's no
bringing her back from this okay take a
listen to this driving out of this Ohio
parking lot is a woman who just attended
a church service with dozens of other
people including children aren't you
concerned you cook in fact other people
if you get sick you very much so that's
what we call weaponised honestly I don't
even know what we call that it's idiocy
its idiocy but again it's someone who
has she's just enough of a quick thinker
and articulate enough that she believes
she's making sense and you're never
going to talk her out of it like there
is no talking sense into that person and
so you know that that's you're
absolutely right James absolutely right
let's see baby grib says we could send
you a mag a hat that's okay
Matt Chavez says please contact and do
something with Brian Tyler Cowan I've
heard of him I don't really know I don't
know much about him but I've heard of
him bass the dragon says thank you for
all the work you and your team do the
briefing streams give me life Thank You
Steven Kenneth bunnell ii says who
should now lead to the progressive
movement i should i should lead the
progressive movement thank you k WB says
clearly all of these donators and subs
are sore
funded yes super chats are actually
covers they are actually Soros people
okay let me say thank you to Elliot
Wolfson Elliot Wolfson has just signed
up for what we call the Big Boi that's
the four hundred and eighty dollar a
year membership that's the biggest one
that we have as Donald Trump would say
Elliot thank you we only have we don't
have that many members at that level
really appreciate your support
Eric Kaplan is new member number 45
today Ola uh echo is new member number
46 Augie doggie is new member number 47
and Steven Sampson is new member number
48 because it seems like the press
briefing may start soon I'm gonna do the
reverse combing now just because people
asked for it okay I haven't been able to
get a haircut for months let's just see
what happens if I do a reverse comb okay
here we go
it doesn't actually not that much seems
to be happening it's just kind of
flattening my hair it's kind of like a
Beatles look I can't even see a damn
thing now so that that's reversed comb
and I don't think that that's really
doing too much for me man it's suckle oh
my god this is almost like some kind of
Justin Bieber look imagine if this was
my new haircut yeah it's like a Tom
DeLonge sort of thing how here it is
that I guess it's kind of emo right is
this like it's it's I've never used a
brush like this before it's very very
different it's very very different
alright but I don't really this is not
going well I don't really like it but I
think we're gonna go back to this there
we go now what happens if I reverse comb
the sides yeah it's just not working
guys I don't think it really does
anything I don't think it does anything
Oh a 50/50 is that back on one side and
then up on the other let's see
yeah I I just don't think it's working I
actually think I might need an exorcism
because it's just not I'm gonna have to
do something for the stream tonight
because this is it's just not good it's
just not good I think I'm gonna leave it
like this for now and then later I'll
see if I'm able to get anything let's
see yeah all right it's done I guess
so we did that experiment and it's over
so now we will get back to the serious
stuff my friends oh my god I gained 500
viewers while I was doing that can you
imagine that's crazy
Oh people are saying I'm brushing it the
wrong way that I'm brushing it like you
would brush a dog's hair I've never used
one of these brushes before I don't know
what the right way is okay left people
demanding I shaved my head out of
respect for my bald brother that that
maybe maybe Alex Espinoza
with a spanish super chat says saludos
this the Tijuana Mexico
greetings from Tijuana in Mexico thank
you I appreciate that
uh let's see Steven Kenneth bunnell ii
says what's your current relationship
with dave rubin nonexistent let me see I
can tell you the date that we last
texted oh I'm getting oh hey Matt Matt
huh my friend Matt Steinberg has
notified me that he is only watching the
briefings to see my hair you know I uh I
had a call today with my youtube rep and
by the way I have to tell you I say so
many horrible things about YouTube my
YouTube rep I have a new YouTube rep
he's been fantastic we had a long call
today he praised my streams he said that
at YouTube his whole team is aware of
the daily streams I've been doing and
how I've been building community and we
have thousands of people that are here
every day watching and they just love it
and YouTube is actually being really
supportive asking how people are doing
with the virus and all of that stuff
okay my last okay when did I last talked
to Dave Rubin I will tell you right now
I last spoke
- Reuben June 23rd of 2018 privately
okay and as many of you know when I was
out for out in LA for it was a perfect
phone call at the time when I was out in
LA for a politican there was like a
Twitter spat where I had asked him if I
could go on and we could you know clear
the air and he said he was out of town
that day but then that same day Tucker
Carlson was on and I tweeted I guess
you're not out of town and he didn't
like it and you know it was the whole
thing but I've not had any contact with
Dave Rubin for for a very long time at
this point
Kobi Carlton is a SOI boy on YouTube
thank you
unknown prodigy says put a picture of
your wild hair as a free space in bingo
that's not a bad idea
Sean goob has signed up on YouTube
Brent Hess says to like oh I lost that
who like on mobile clothes live chat hit
like yeah so listen if you're trying if
you're trying to destroy my YouTube
channel
don't do anything okay and I know
there's at least a few hundred of you
here if you want to help my YouTube
channel do consider hitting the like
button and the subscribe button if you
are on mobile at least on Android I
don't know if this applies on iPhone
iPhone you have to close Live Chat to
pound like and to pound subscribe so
just be aware of that my friends be
aware of that sensible talk says what do
you make of the Trump Biden phone call I
don't know what to make of it so as far
as we've been told
Trump and Biden had a phone call
yesterday Biden made some suggestions to
Trump Trump said they were fair
suggestions but not necessarily
suggestions that he's going to accept
and they Trump said they both agreed not
to disclose the specific contents of the
phone call I don't know I mean that
that's all I've read at this point in
time I don't know anything else about it
inconsolable says I'm pretty sure
Wisconsin Republicans just want to co
vid kill a bunch of Democrats voting
today I mean it's that that would be a
horrible
if indeed it is it is the case Alexandra
Stevenson says hoping you grow out your
hair during the confinement back balm DP
distant socializing is more entertaining
with bingo quaff updates and chess ok
Thank You Alexandra
stew guy says if bernie windsor comes
close in wisconsin today do you think it
could potentially swing the primary in
Bernie's favor uh you know I I mean
probably not let me look at the polling
in Wisconsin I haven't seen what is
going on there let's take a look at it
together while we're waiting here okay
Wisconsin Democratic primary the latest
poll is a week old and it had Biden plus
28 I mean you know Biden plus 28 what
what do you mean by if Bernie can keep
it close it's hard to imagine I don't
see it I don't see it
skunk games says Soros made me send this
Travis Myers sends a super chat cam-cam
has signed up at the soy boy level make
it simple and junior balligan have
subscribed have supported incredible TV
says lol here's 5 bucks just because of
the hair Arda when says with that hair
David has transformed into Dave oh let
me show you guys something pretty funny
this was um someone posted this to
Twitter and I posted it to my Instagram
check this out I think you might like
this
this is a screenshot from yesterday let
me zoom it out this is a I don't know if
you guys are familiar with Vidal Sassoon
but I have just signed a very very
lucrative deal with Vidal Sassoon now
the funny thing is it's nothing it's not
clear if the product is supposed to fix
what's going on in this picture or cause
it right like it's not clear if this is
a before picture so to speak we're like
if
having this problem you buy this product
to fix to fix this problem or if this is
actually the goal like is this the
outcome of having this product I don't I
don't really know you would think they'd
be advertising the results right like
that's usually the way these products
work but anyway yeah that's that's
serious and I posted that to my to my
Instagram page which is David Pakman
okay let me thank a few other people
here let's see did I think wow I think I
did
Warren Higgins did I thank Warren I
don't think I did Warren Higgins is new
member number 49 and Rob Thomas the
great Rob Thomas is new member number 50
let's go for 75 my friends why not why
not okay
the room is starting to fill up we are
not seeing any we're not seeing too many
masks there although increasingly
yesterday we saw masks today we are not
seeing too many masks and the the real
question is will we see Trump's new
press secretary Kaylee McKenna Nita day
as a quick reminder this is Donald
Trump's new press secretary on the left
here take a listen to this looking at
the coronavirus and the president saying
you know look we're not gonna take
people in from China right now I mean
isn't it just a matter of protecting us
our national security really being at
stake and he's sort of the last line of
defense there or firstly I should say
absolutely this president will always
put America first
he will always protect American citizens
we will not see diseases like the corona
virus come here we will not see
terrorism come here and isn't that
refreshing when contrasting it with the
awful presidency of President Obama yes
so that would be by the way trish regan
is not trump's new press secretary Kaley
McKenna Diaz this tret type of delusion
would get you would would basically be
career-ending in a lot of fields Caylee
McKenna knee has gotten herself a
promotion so you know make of that what
you will we have dr. Burks entering her
her outfits getting increasingly
reflective over time we have Seema Verma
and we have dr. Anthony foutch II as
many of you know I have become an
authoritarian foul chist as of late Sima
Verma absolutely horrible health care
consultant who recently said that we're
terrible at coronavirus because we are
not because we are a free country unlike
South Korea note that South Korea is
higher on the democracy index than the
United States very very weird and as
many of you know dr. Burks or dr. BRICS
as she was called yesterday I don't
think she can fully be trusted recently
saying that she is impressed with how
Donald Trump assimilates data to make
good decisions and obviously none of us
believe that so we have you know a lot
of people here that we can't really
trust can't really trust to a great
degree a Bridget slick says thank you
for making these briefings tolerable
Thank You Christian birdy L says I've
been going to a restaurant with the big
chicken near my house and they've been
following all the guidelines but then I
go to another in a different area and no
gloves or baskets I don't know what
you're talking about Christian I
apologize thank you to sue Shauna grant
and Theodore caper for grabbing YouTube
memberships Christian Burrell says where
did that go shave your head and give it
to your brother and have him do the show
one time maybe one day as a goof I will
have my brother host a stream that's not
he's working from home so that's an idea
dr. Burks is signaling something she's
doing a lot of this I don't know what
that means uh weird okay MK star 12 says
donate your hair cacus Umbra says how
many members for a bald Pakman yeah it's
going to take a lot more than 50 members
to get me to shave my head all right
let's go Donald Trump here remember I'll
be here not until the end because I do
have to go prepare for tonight's stream
[Music]
today we continue to send our love to
the great people of New York and New
Jersey we support them fully what we
grieve alongside every family who has
lost a precious loved one
New Yorkers are tough and strong and
brave New Jersey i'ts are tough and
strong and brave and they're being hit
very hard right now and for the next
week hopefully not much longer than that
it's gonna start to go in the other
direction and be a little long our
country is being hit hard but some areas
have done so incredibly well we're so
proud of them they will beat this virus
we're gonna beat it with the grit in the
heart for which they're known and for
which our country is known and we
appreciate everything that everybody is
doing we also we pray for Prime Minister
Boris Johnson has become a great friend
of ours he loves this country he loves
his country but he loves the USA and
he's always been very good to us
whenever we had difficulty he was with
us and we appreciate it so we pray for
Prime Minister Boris Johnson Trump's a
lot as we intensify our military
campaign against the virus I think that
it must be brought out that we have to
thank the American people for continuing
to follow our guidelines on slowing the
spread an expression that more and more
people are thinking about nobody ever
heard of it two months ago and now I
think I think slowing the spread
stopping this spread even during this
painful week we see glimmers of very
very strong hope and this will be very
painful week and next week at least part
of next week but probably all of it look
if one person dies that's a painful week
and we know that's going to
unfortunately happen this is a monster
we're fighting but signs are that our
strategy is totally working every
American has a role to play and
winning this war and we're going to be
winning it we're gonna be winning it
powerfully and we'll be prepared for the
next one should it happen but hopefully
it won't our massive you guys hear that
it's like someone's what's that noise
that's weird
it's called project air bridge continued
today as five massive planes flights
landed in the United States packed with
personal protective equipment and our
nation's heroic health care workers will
be the beneficiaries of that
twenty-seven more flights are scheduled
in the near future over the next couple
of weeks the Army Corps of Engineers is
constructing facilities that will
support more than 15,000 hospital beds
to treat patients in need so they're
building now approximately 15,000 they
just completed the big one in New York
they've just completed enter in the
process of continuing in Chicago and
many other places they're incredible the
Army Corps of Engineers we owe them a
lot what they were able to do in such a
short period of time they'll build these
massive facilities 2,000 beds in four
days so it's really something very
special I know I was in the construction
industry and you don't see that happen
very often I want to remind governor's
and emergency managers that sharing real
time data with us about equipment and
their needs is very important all of
their supplies hospital occupancy is
critical a lot of the occupancy is
really getting a little bit lower than
anticipated and that's good we sort of
thought that was going to happen and
we're getting along very well with the
governor's this whole situation with
respect to talking to us about equipment
and equipment knees giving us a little
bit of lead time so important all the
supplies we're getting it to everybody
like they never thought possible but
we'll ensure that we can rapidly deploy
federal assets where and when they're
needed especially on ventilators we're
actually
getting some mental eaters back as you
know the state of California was great
they sent some back which they won't
need he does look less orange today
could be a white balance issue and we
have some others coming back so we're
using them in areas we need them we are
pressing forward aggressively on the
scientific frontier of the medical war
the companies I've spoke to the four
leading I comb the genius companies
they're doing incredibly well with
respect to cures and also with respect
to a vaccine that's going to protect us
totally protect us and they have some
great potential it's going to take a
little while yet but they have some
great potential some great early results
and the governor has been working hard
and we are working hard with the
governor's has been great coordination
especially over the last little while we
give them a lot of equipment a lot of
ventilators but a lot of equipment of
all types and I will protect you if
you're governor fails if you have a
governor that's failing we're going to
protect you but the governors are
working well with that's an interesting
reversal because it's really Trump
failing the governor's today in our
stockpile of ventilators and again we
need the stockpile so we can immediately
move them from place to place wherever
the monster hits it's a monster we have
eight thousand six hundred and seventy
five ventilators right now in stock
ready to move and we have all sorts of
incredible soldiers our military is
going to move them should they be needed
in as an example if we need additional
in New York or or the New York City area
if state you have City and spoke to
mayor de Blasio and we really have a
great well coordinated campaign with
mayor de Blasio it's been really good
spoke to Governor Cuomo it's been great
coordination so if they need something
we have it if Louisiana needs something
we have it
same thing with Michigan's same thing
with Illinois there are certain spots
that are very hot
and we'll see what happens but we'll
know pretty much we'll have time and
we'll be able to move it in addition to
the eight thousand six hundred and
seventy five ventilators we have two
thousand two hundred arriving on April
13th we have five thousand five hundred
arriving on May fourth these are ones
that we're building for the most part
and we have as you know great companies
building them for generators we just
don't know yeah GE
we have could be aligned great companies
that are doing it on may 18th we have
twelve thousand on June 1st we have
twenty thousand on June 29th we have
sixty thousand ventilators now I'm
regarding to doubt these numbers are
real so we have a total of a hundred and
ten thousand ventilators coming over a
short period of time I don't think we'll
need them hopefully we won't need them I
don't think we'll need anywhere near
them but we'll have them for the future
and we'll also be able to help other
countries who are desperate for
ventilators the UK called today and they
wanted to know would it be possible to
get 200 and we're going to work it out
we got to work it out they've been great
partners United Kingdom and we're gonna
work it out for them so they wanted 200
they needed them desperately we now have
10 drugs in active trials with 15 more
soon to follow as well as to vaccine
candidates in active clinical trials
we'll do whatever it takes to secure
needed medical supplies and bring more
production of essential medicines back
to our shores we're doing that we're
bringing them back to our shores
live these companies they went a little
bit haywire they went away from this
great country and they had them produced
elsewhere so we're gonna start bringing
it back I've been talking about that for
a long time not only with medical but
lots of other things America continues
to perform more tests than any other
nation in the world and I think that's
probably why we have more cases not per
capita because when you look at some of
these very large countries they I know
they I know for a fact that they have
far more cases than we do but they don't
report them
we've performed 1.87 million tests today
so that's 1 million eight hundred and
seventy thousand million tests thinking
about 1 million eight hundred and
seventy thousand tests to date and now
we're performing them at a level that
nobody's ever seen before as we
announced yesterday CVS testing sites in
Georgia and Rhode Island will be using
Abbott Labs rapid five-minute tests
we're down to now five minutes it's a
five minute test so that people can get
their results back very quickly and
we're actively engaging on the problem
of increased impacts there's a real
problem and it's showing up very
strongly and our data on the
african-american community and we're
doing everything in our power to address
this challenge it's a tremendous
challenge it's terrible and provide
support to African American citizens of
this country who are going through a lot
but it's been disproportional they're
getting hit very very hard in fact while
we have Tony here I'd like to maybe have
you come up and address that one and
then I'll continue but please let it -
this will be great more dad we have a
particularly difficult problem of an
exacerbation of a health disparity we've
known literally forever
that diseases like diabetes hypertension
obesity and asthma are
disproportionately afflicting the
minority populations particularly the
African Americans unfortunately when you
look at the predisposing conditions that
lead to a bad outcome with coronavirus
the things that get people into our
ciues that require intubation and often
lead to death
they are just those very comorbidities
that are unfortunately
disproportionately prevalent in the
african-american population so we're
very concerned about that it's very sad
it's nothing we can do about it right
now except to try and give them the best
possible care to avoid those
complications
thank you very much and Tony I think
you're gonna have some pretty accurate
numbers over the next few days right but
they are very they're very nasty numbers
terrible numbers in total 1200 Abbot
machines average Laboratories have been
fantastic have been shipped now
nationwide up to 500 more are being
produced every week remember
yesterday he said it was 18,000 were
already out is he now saying that it's
1200 or is this 1200 more we just don't
know we have no idea
world has developed a more diverse and
robust testing capacity than the United
States we're dealing with other nations
helping them out because the testing is
very tough for them and our tests are
very accurate a lot of tests are out
there and they're not accurate at all in
fact some of the tests you don't have a
clue what's going on so we're working
with other nations trying to get them
help also at a time when many Americans
are experiencing increased stress
anxiety and personal loss we must also
ensure that our country can meet the
mental health needs of those struggling
in this crisis there are people
struggling they're struggling and some
people are getting to know each other
frankly some families are getting to
know each other on their note but there
are a lot of people struggling one
Thursday I'll be speaking to leaders and
advocates from the mental health
organizations all across our country and
we are going to be talking about
resources and tools that will make
available to them they need help and
it's a big problem when you take
something where it was the most
successful country in the world still is
the whole world is shut down
think of it we're down to numbers that
are incredible as I said yesterday I
think it's 182 countries right now 182
countries are under attack by the by the
scourge scores virus but as we wage
medical war on the virus
we're also speeding economic relief to
our people it's incredible we just had a
meeting that was
absolutely walkable with sightings I
spoke with leaders in the banking and
finance industry about our efforts to
help American workers and employers as
of today small business has processed
more than seventy billion dollars in
guaranteed loans and will provide
much-needed relief for nearly a quarter
of a million businesses already so we
are going to be providing tremendous
amounts of money to these small
businesses of our country have been
absolutely clobbered and they'll be
keeping open and they'll be paying their
employees and they'll be all set to go
we're gonna have a rocket upward I want
to thank David Solomon CEO of goldman
sachs brian moynihan CEO of Bank of
America gordon smith co-president CEO of
JPMorgan Chase Josh aarif CEO of Wells
Fargo these again Michael Corbitt CEO of
Citigroup al Kelly CEO of Visa Michael
me bak CEO of MasterCard
it's an at Noah Wilcox CEO chairman of
Grand Rapids State Bank and we had
numerous others also on the call and I
just appreciate them they are well way
ahead of schedule
by the way we're way ahead of schedule
the Paycheck protection program has been
incredible so based on the incredible
success of the program I'm announcing
that I'll be asking Congress to provide
an additional 250 billion dollars for
the Paycheck protection which will help
keep Americans employed to facilitate a
quick and full recovery we're doing very
well we're looking very bipartisan a lot
of people want to do it and the the plan
is amazing you know they're processing
hundreds of thousands of loans and this
is the big banks that are doing it the
community banks so but the biggest banks
right now and understand your Graham
unfortunately they're doing it for a lot
of reasons one of them is they want to
help people
the w-h-o that's the world health
organization receives vast amounts of
money from the United States and we pay
for a majority or biggest portion of
their money not a majority obviously and
they actually criticized and disagreed
with my travel ban at the time I did it
and they were wrong they've been wrong
about a lot of things and then a lot of
information early and they didn't want
to do very they seem to be very china
centric and we have to look into that so
we're going to look into it we pay for
we give a majority of the money that
can't be true and it's much more than
the fifty eight fifty eight million
dollars is a small portion of what
they've gotten over the years sometimes
they get much more than that sometimes
it's for programs that they're doing and
and it's much bigger numbers and if the
programs are good that's great as far as
we're concerned but we want to look into
a World Health Organization because they
really are they called it wrong they
call it wrong they really they missed
the call they could have called it
months earlier they would have known and
they should have known and they probably
didn't know so crumpets brief in
December to that very carefully and
we're gonna put a hold on money spent to
the w-h-o we're gonna put a very
powerful hold on it and we're gonna see
powerful it's a great thing if it works
but when they call every shot wrong
that's no good we're in the midst of a
great national struggle one that
requires the shared sacrifice of all
Americans in recent weeks it's been
remarkable to see so many companies and
organizations and individuals like the
banks that I just told you about biggest
banks in the world great for the big
bang stepped up to help small business
they're big business small business
small business will someday be the big
business but the small business is 50%
of our economic strength people don't
realize when you add them up but they
just they just rose to the occasion
everybody's rising to the occasion it's
been incredible to watch to honor and
celebrate the extraordinary examples of
patriotism and
citizenship we're seeing I'm asking
Americans to use the hashtag America
works together Oh God when sharing
stories of how we're all working
together get through getting through
this ordeal in a fashion that nobody
would have ever thought possible it's
been incredible and that's why the
numbers are so far much better we want
to keep it that way if you look at the
original projections if we did nothing
it would be disastrous if we we decided
to do something which Brummer this is
the new game now which is after saying
there would be no deaths or very few
deaths now he says if I ignored this
altogether we would have had 2 million
deaths but it's like who would just
ignore it altogether it's an incredibly
insane bar to set thing but we're
looking to have far fewer deaths then
originally thought and I think we're
heading in that direction but it's too
early to talk about it I don't even want
to talk about it now because we just
want to work and I think that people are
doing an incredible job the doctors the
nurses the firefighters the police all
medical people what they're doing the
bravery that they're displaying is just
incredible every citizen should take
immense pride and the selfless
selflessness and all of the courage and
compassion of our people the workers the
the people that are working and
construction workers going into
hospitals knowing nothing about this
problem other than it's dangerous and
they go in there to rebuild sections of
hospitals and you have people in really
big trouble right next door they know
nothing about it all they know is
they're gonna get it done they're gonna
fix that wing so they can have more
people in there it's incredible but this
is a national spirit that won our
independence and settled the frontier
and explored the horizons of space and
that's what we're doing I mean this is
all this is all new territory it unlock
the miracles of science and we're doing
that when you I wish you could have
heard the calls I had yesterday with
perfect great come
that come up with cures to diseases and
the success they've had over the last 15
years is really amazing so I just want
to thank all of them they're working
very hard they're working with UK right
now in the UK doctors hopefully helping
with their great prime minister but
these people are really tremendous signs
of success are staring us right in the
face I think we're gonna have something
that's gonna be great in terms of
vaccines and in terms of everything else
that they're doing just helping really
helping us helping the people of our
country and helping ultimately the
people of the world so I want to thank
you all for being here I will take some
questions and then I'm gonna give it
over to the vice president and they're
gonna go into great detail on to what
we're doing and all of the successful
your eyes and medical equipment that
we're getting all of the ventilators
I've said it but you can go over it in
more detail if you'd like but we're
taken in and building thousands and
thousands of enta laters and right
they're very high quality I said you got
to go for the quality and these are
quality companies doing it so because
there is a big difference between a good
ventilator and their not so good
ventilator Tony right we've seen that Oh
Tony just loved a big difference so
we're thrilled happy the line Steve
please the Acting Navy secretary
submitted his resignation today motely
why did that become necessary and what
role did you have in this sir well I
have no role in it I've heard I don't
know him but I've heard he was a very
good man and it was a the whole thing
was a very unfortunate the captain
should not have written a letter he
didn't have to be Ernest Hemingway he
made a mistake the big day and I hate
seeing bad things happen Oh Stan we're
screwed but you know you shouldn't be
writing letters and you should you're in
the military you're the captain of a
great ship and you shouldn't be writing
letters and sending them too many people
and right you should be captaining then
it gets out to the media and you know
the question is how did it get out to
the media so there's a lot of bad things
happen there and
I had heard he did because he didn't
want to cause any disturbance for our
country so that was a because he
wouldn't have had to resign I would not
have asked him I don't know him I didn't
speak to him but he did that I think
just to end in that problem I think one
in really many ways that was a very
unselfish thing for him Thomas no clue
now the commander Crozier who I think
the Secretary of Defense as you know is
what you know Mark Esper and he's very
capable and I think he's looking at that
right now they're they're going to just
take it under regular Navy channels to
see what they want to do but he made a
mistake but he shouldn't have done that
and your secretary probably shouldn't
have said quite what he said he didn't
have to resign but he felt it would be
better for the country so I you know I
think it's it will end it quickly couple
on the economic front the two hundred
fifty billion dollars that was at it
there will be added for the small
business loan program brings it to six
hundred billion in total do you think
that figure is enough - well I know when
you see hundreds of thousands of
applications don't forget I'm gonna duck
over this because it's just it's I want
to explain the answer doesn't matter the
everyday saying is this amount of money
or that amount of money enough the
questions Trump calls nasty aren't nasty
when Trump tells someone they should be
ashamed of themselves it's usually a
good question but every day do you think
this is enough do you think that's
enough it we really just don't know and
a lot of it is do people actually get
the money or is it just announced little
cub just like we're gonna help the
airlines and the big companies we're
gonna help the little companies and the
banks are running nobody's equipped to
do a thing like that but the banks are
equipped right Trump likes these quite
banks they're eating at big banks small
banks we have many banks community banks
and they're processing the loans and
they'll be able to watch it and make
sure it's done properly
today sir as well about potentially
reopening the economy in the upcoming
weeks you mentioned the other day about
a potential economic taskforce can you
give us some sort of update as to where
thinking about that but we want to open
up but we want to get it open soon
that's why I think maybe we're getting
to the very top of the curve
I spoke with Governor Cuomo and he seems
to think that he's getting close and I
think a lot of people think that a lot
of places are getting close we want to
start heading that hitting the downside
and I think we're gonna be dude this is
gonna be a very difficult week however
this week will be a very difficult week
because that's the most difficult week
when you're at that position and we'll
see what happens and it's gonna do a lot
we wanna I really think that with the
stimulus we can be maybe even beyond
we're gonna do perhaps infrastructure
which you wouldn't have gotten approved
before and now people are looking to do
it and the beauty is we're paying zero
interest or very close to zero interest
and so guess is we're paying actually
zero have no interest charge and the
dollar is very strong and people are
investing in the dollar they want you
know the fact that we have the strong
currency we have the currency we our
currency is is everything the dollars
and other companies other countries want
to be in our currency so we're we're
getting all of the investment wanting to
come into the dollar the dollar is the
strength the dollar is the whole
ballgame we have a strong dollar other
currencies are going down way way down
in some cases you look at other
countries this is the guy who called
Michael Flynn in the middle of the night
to ask is a strong dollar good or bad
for us Mike tenth and it's very hard for
them that Mike said I'm a military guy I
asked an economist currency is
relatively now stronger than it ever was
or it was over the last few years
relative to other countries it's always
relative to other countries but our
currency is very strong so therefore
people want to invest if we do a bond
issue to do infrastructure everybody
wants a piece of that issue even at zero
interest yeah please
that's a real story cds memos that
reportedly Peter Navarro wrote back in
January when did you see them and how
does that these memos sort of square
with what you've often said that nobody
could have predicted this it sounds like
he was predicting I didn't see him but I
heard he wrote some memos talking about
pandemic talking about pandemic I didn't
see him ID to look for him either but
that was about the same time who's the
right now that we should do it we'd
there was about the same time that I
closed it down I asked him about it just
a little while ago cuz I read something
close noting March 12th was the day of
the China ban or Europe ban now I don't
remember I think you were banned January
he didn't close anything down that booty
of Panda but nobody said it's going to
happen but you know there is a
possibility there always has been a
possibility but people wouldn't talk
about it but it was right about the time
that I closed it down
Branko interestingly the World Health
Organization was not in favor of us new
scapegoat and if we didn't close it down
we would have lost hundreds of thousands
more lives
Peter Navarro did circulate those memos
you were still downplaying the threat of
coronavirus of us you were saying things
like I think it's a problem that's going
to go away with him so ready to go ahead
we'll go you said within a couple of
days this cases will be down to zero
well the cases really didn't build up
for a while you understand how much
cheerleader for this country right I'm
gonna just lie and say everything's fine
havoc and shock and everything else but
ultimately when I was saying that I'm
also closing it down I obviously
concerned about it because I closed down
our country to China which was heavily
infected I then closed it down to Europe
that's a big move Clark well from China
and then closing it down from Europe and
then ultimately closing it down to the
UK so and what might at that time but
I'm not gonna go out and start screaming
this could happen this could happen
that's what you do to some people again
as president I think a president has to
be a cheerleader for their country but
at the same time I'm cheerleading I'm
also closing down
a very highly infected place
specifically so decision as you lying
not taking responsibility and just being
wrong about what a president should do
all-in-one to all of Europe and it was a
recommendation was a feeling that he had
Trump saying it's reasonable for memos
to be written but no one gives them to
him or tells him about them that's what
Trump's arguing right now isn't being
discussed we had a meeting where there
were a lot of people most people felt
they should not close it down that we
shouldn't close down to China but I felt
we had to do it and that was almost the
exact same time as the memo changed the
change because I did I basically did
what the memo said and that was you know
the memo was pretty good memo from the
standpoint that he took I guess I didn't
see it yet the u.s. blue morning that
the US could lose trillions of dollars
and millions of lives but you you'll
lose plenty of money but I couldn't have
done it any better cause it was about
the same time and I closed it down to
China he didn't need to see the memos he
did everything right confidence it
who is that man he wrote a memo and he
was right and I haven't seen him ignore
to see it later on after this Ivan said
it didn't matter whether I saw it or not
because I I acted on my own I guess I
had the same instinct says Peter Peter
is a smart guy he's a good guy
pretzel and he's done a wonderful job
but he wrote a memo and I guess he
talked to various people about it but
ultimately I did what the memo more or
less what the memo said just about the
time the memo came out and what a lot
and I took a lot of heat the world you
know health organization was very much
against it lightly income actually put
out statements about it
in all fairness to Joe Biden he called
me xenophobic like I don't like China I
like China like the Chinese people are
phenomenal people love Chinese food so I
was called xenophobic I was called
racist how could I do a thing like this
now since then Joe said that he was
wrong and he said that I was right but I
closed it down and I was called names by
some of the morning show hosts who don't
have a clue what they're talking about
they're not smart people and I was
called all sorts of names when I closed
it down to China now they try and hide
that you know the tape of saying
terrible things but that was a great
decision if I didn't do it if I didn't
do that we would have had hundreds of
thousands more people dying yeah please
wh oh and I was wondering dr. fauci had
discussed them earlier so if I could ask
you a question wh oh and I think that's
that's good and again doesn't want you
to answer questions about they did give
us some pretty bad play calling I think
given lots of countries in the world
cron virus testing that's been central
to your guys data model and so that I
don't know I can only say that with
regard to us they're taking a lot of
heat because they didn't want the
borders closed they called it wrong they
called they really called I would say
every aspect of it wrong until the woman
freeze look we fund it take a look at me
go through step by step they said
there's no big deal there's no big
problem there's no nothing and then
ultimately when I closed it down they
actually said that I made a mistake in
closing it down and it turned out to be
right but a totally incoherent oh they
did that so we're just gonna take a look
at it you know we fund it and and they
seem to be you know I said recently a
social media said they seem to be very
china centric that's a nice one wearing
it but they seem to be very china
centric and they received it they're
always on the side of China and we fund
it you know so I want to look into it
yes follow up on that so it's the time
to freeze funding to the WHL during a
pandemic oh maybe not I mean I'm not
saying I'm going to do it but we're
going to look at it you did we give a
command I said we're gonna look at it
we're going to investigate it we're
gonna look at it didn't he think they
were doing it indeed he said they're
doing it yeah cuz you know what they
called it wrong and if you look back
over the years even they're very much
everything seems to be very biased
toward China that's not right
to follow up talked about African
Americans and having been
disproportionately
goodbye the corona fire civilian fortune
to use plan are requiring the CDC of any
federal agencies or estate agents public
public places doing tests and private
companies doing tests to collect that
data on the race other people being
tested and the the race of the people
being treated and how are we just seeing
tremendous we're seeing tremendous
evidence that African Americans are
affected at a far greater percentage
collecting race testing data other
citizens of our country because we're
dealing with our country now we're
looking at it from a worldwide
standpoint Tony Fauci is looking at it
very strongly but these numbers have
started to come out and then they're
very strong and they're pretty obvious
question was about yeah get him out of
there one of the things that we're gonna
be doing with our Medicare data is to do
that analysis we're gonna look back at
the last month or so and look at you
know related type illnesses going
forward we now have a code for
coronavirus so we can actually stratify
by demographic information so we can
look at race as a factor we can also
look at what the underlying health
issues are as well so we'll be providing
that data very shortly this is something
that's come up over the list
I hadn't heard this and then over the
last few days this has come up we've
actually known about it for a couple
weeks I don't mean by a little bit I
mean many times it's a real thing now we
want Trump just learn something he
imagines everybody just learned it
vaccines because that will solve
everybody's problem but why is it that
the African American community is so
much you know numerous times more than
everybody else and we want to find the
reason to it and called poverty my bias
of them and others are working on this
and they can be have virtually no I
would say over the next in less than a
week I think you're gonna have very good
statistics couple of days
we aimed at those communities that are
being hard-hit those black communities
were helping them a lot but what's
happening is we're trying to find out
why is it that it's three and four times
down we know what's not going to be the
final number but why is it three or four
times your God would it be more so for
the black community as opposed to other
people it doesn't make sense and I don't
like it
and we're going to have students where
are the good hospitals my friend what
kind of food do you buy if you are
economically disadvantaged and is that
food likely to create preexisting
comorbid I mean it's like you know this
is a whole class right you know with
Hearst Newspapers I'm the prisoner today
thank you some base are only providing
paycheck protection program loans to
clients with whom they have existing
banking relationships - and you spoke to
banking CEOs today I wonder if you
you'll ask them these lenders to accept
applications from all small businesses
not just the businesses with whom they
have existed and they'll be doing this
but we're also working with small
community banks so they will be doing
that it's a question I've already spoken
about I mean in many cases they have
long term relationships with thousands
of companies I was amazed to see how
many you know you saw the number of
applications it's hundreds of thousands
it's a lot of work but I did ask that
question and they are working on that
yeah thank you and my my second question
from a colleague is congressman Gerry
Connolly a Democrat from Northern
Virginia told the local DC CBS station
that you personally requested the Kerr's
act stimulus bill
be stripped of 25 billion dollars for
the Postal Service Connelly claims that
unless the USPS gets that 25 billion the
agency will be run out of money by June
crook he accuses you of hastening the
demise of the Postal Service I'm the
reason the Postal Service service has
lost billions of dollars every year from
many many years I'm the division 375
years from now that reminds of our
Postal Service I'll tell you who's the
demise of the Postal Service so these
Internet companies that give their stuff
to the Postal Service packages and I
don't know why they're not you know I
don't run the Postal Service you have a
group of people so-called independent
people and they run it but these
packages are they deliver they lose
money every time they deliver a package
for Amazon or these other Internet
companies these other companies that
deliver drop everything in the post
office they say you deliver it and if
they'd raise the prices by actually a
lot then you'd find out that the post
office could make money or break even
but they don't do that and I'm trying to
figure out why these are independent
boards that were appointed by other
administrations they're sort of long
term they're there for a long time and
I've been talking to them also you can
look it up take a look they should raise
they have to raise the prices to these
companies that walk in and drop
thousands of packages on the floor of
the post office and say deliver it and
they make money but the post office gets
killed
and um okay so they ought to do that and
we look through it and we've been
pushing them now for over a year and you
know that because you've seen the
stories I'm pushing them it's not fair
for them to to these great wonderful
modern companies they walk into our old
post office with all these routes that
could never be built
you could never build them they go into
areas at you you could never do and they
say here deliver this and they lose a
lot of money per package and they have
to raise their prices but this postal
Commission doesn't do it now we just got
a chance to point a couple of people
onto the Commission as I understand it
and that's good but they have to raise
their prices otherwise they're just
going to lose a lot of money and tell
you
a friend that he ought to focus on that
because if he focused on that you're
truly saved the post office post office
has been losing billions of dollars a
year from many many years and have him
take a look at that because that's the
way to solve the problems then you say
this we could be very painful very
difficult but a few weeks ago you say
this was just like a flu what have you
alarm I just said two weeks ago this is
me to foreign leaders who still are
acceptable about this pandemic and were
against social decency what is your
advice you said I said it was just like
a flu so the worst pandemic we ever had
Oh in this world was a flu and it was
called you know that it was in 1917 1918
and anywhere from fifty to a hundred
million people died that was a flu now
by percentage was that you could say
that I said it was a flu or you could
say the flu is nothing to sneeze at
what can you offer as identify Safari
leaders who are skeptical skeptical
about these polemic a war against social
distancing well I think there aren't too
many of them if you look throughout the
world and everyone just about everyone
that but your audience that is now
closing up look at the Brazilian the
unified thing now they talk about Sweden
but Sweden is suffering very gravely you
know that right Sweden did that the
heard they call it the heard Sweden
suffering very very badly it's a way of
doing it but the you know everybody has
been watching everybody else and so far
almost every country has done it the way
we've done it we've chosen to do it if
we didn't do it that way we would have
lost hundreds of thousands of more
people okay
this president there's voting going on
today in Wisconsin there were points of
thousands of people waiting in hours
long lines as they've had to wait around
personal health and their civic
responsibilities what do you think that
the Supreme Court was right in students
or that that voting should go forward
the absentee extension should all take
place look the Supreme Court of course
they were right because what the
Democrats wanted and and you know what
this happened I supported it a man named
Justice Kelly who's Daniel Kelly highly
respected justice and I supported him
just the other day social media I know
of him he's a just a you know fantastic
judge justice and I endorsed him and as
soon as I endorsed him they wanted to
move the election they didn't want to
move the election as soon as I endorsed
him the Wisconsin Democrats say oh let's
move the election to two months later
three they didn't mind having the
election until I endorsed him which is
very interesting now they talk about Oh
safety safety well it was 15 minutes
after I put out an endorsement this as
they said we have to move the election
they didn't want to move the election
before that the other thing they want to
do which told me at the end of the
election they wanted to have one week
for proxies to come in or mail ballots
no mail ballots they cheat okay
people cheat mail ballots a very
dangerous thing for this country because
they assure us that they're going to let
him read therefore in other cases you
got a vote and they should have voter ID
by the way you want to really do it
right yeah voter ID but the Democrats
and this was turned over in the Supreme
Court yesterday I give great credit to
the court they actually didn't want to
have an election day they wanted to have
election day and then a week after
election day you choose you can't but
all these ballots come in these mailed
ballots come in the mail ballots are
corrupt in my opinion and they collect
them and they get people to go in and
sign them and then mostly Republicans or
juries in many cases it's a horrible
thing and so what happened is the
Democrats in Wisconsin they had no
problem with the election being today
until I endorsed the Republican
candidate that is justice Kelly
newkeli and as soon as I endorsed him
they went crazy they went crazy and you
know that's true and now all of a sudden
because go back two weeks go back two
days they didn't want to move the
election they were having the election
they will find cuz they don't why your
election then I endorsed him and all of
a sudden they think they're not now I
understand there are lines that go back
a long way I hope they're gonna vote for
justice Kelley hydroxychloroquine
donated is there a plan or system in
place side effects the side effects are
the least of it you have people dying
all over the place and generally the
side effects are really with the z-pak
having to do with the heart the z-pak
that's the antibiotic not with the
hydroxychloroquine also odd a woman last
night I watched her on one of the shows
good show Laura and she was she thought
she was dead
she was a representative from this she
thought she said literally during the
filming was just in horrible shape for
12 days 14 days she thought she was dead
I think she said that her doctor said
she's you know it's gonna be very tough
she saw me talking about this and she
asked her husband to go to the drugstore
now this is a Democrat representative a
person that you know perhaps wouldn't be
voting for me I think she'll be voting
for me now even if she's a Democrat even
if she's a Democrat representative and
so they miss acting like he's the only
one talking about chloroquine we started
talking about it two weeks early of
doses we have I think 29 min she is
Trump to thank because the doctor made
the right decision she has two husbands
she said please go out I'm not gonna
make it please you have to hear her
story please go out get it he won at ten
o'clock in the evening to the drugstore
he got it he gave it to her now
you know I don't say it works like this
at all four hours later she awoke won a
weightlifting and then shortly
thereafter she felt great
there's a woman that thought she was
gonna die it's I mean she's a Democrat
represent all my highly affected woman
this is dangerous
african-american woman I don't know if
you saw it as you asked the question
about african-american she was an
African did he disappointed a black
reporter I think wait woman no the way
she told the story was beautiful
I asked my husband to go and get it he
got it she is now okay I mean she was
interviewed last night on television and
she thanked me she thanked me even in a
tweet she said I want to thank President
Trump you saved my life
look I don't say that happens how does
the husband go get something at the
pharmacy that is not like it needs to be
pretty how is this how is the story
coherent please you're gonna die and
you're gonna die I mean it's you're not
gonna die from this bill now there could
be some side effects but the side
effects is really more so from the
secret doctors have to recommend it I
want doctors I'm gonna think I'm not
understanding the question I'm saying we
have great results this guy's horrible
and some people say let's go to a
laboratory let's test it for a couple of
years and then I get we got people dying
in this country and all over the world
right now I'm not in a couple of years
they're dying as we speak there are
people dying and I really think it's a
great thing to try just based on what I
know again I'm not a doctor we know and
I say get a physicians approval and they
have physicians in these hospitals great
physicians we know we know they're sure
the doctors are they also say it's good
for the hospital workers to take them
that it's prophylactic use oh my god is
it away keeps it out of your system
totally unsubstantiated there's a lot of
good examples and you know we have a
because 1,500 case study going in New
York and it's almost complete so it'll
be very interesting to see what happens
for
thank you sir um can you I appreciate
that woman she was great you have to see
it to believe it
right way and she's black did she smoke
it was like woman a miracle and this was
not a fan of mine right but she's a fan
of mine now and I'm very honored by it
go ahead thank you sir can you talk
about your decision to remove Glen fine
from the dynamic responsive
accountability committee and all right
guys I mentioned I can only be here for
part of this because we are streaming
again tonight so we're gonna wrap here
this will continue you decide whether
you want to continue tolerating it but I
will be back with another stream shortly
before 9:00 p.m. Eastern Time with the
results from the Wisconsin primary and
other local elections as well
you